raise your hand if you know what this is  should have thought that I can't see if  you're raising your hand  several hundred years ago long before  you were born this was invented this  simply has one function and it is to  play music  there's no touchscreen there's no  streaming listen to a tape you started  at the beginning you ended at the end  you couldn't hit shuffle couldn't skip  back and forth you couldn't hit repeat  you listened to a tape as if you were  sitting at a concert but all and the  ease and comfort of a walk they call it  a Walkman you put on your head and you  can walk man  do you think you are me star much I'm  not gonna answer star much on May 5th  what you see Papa you only get one  chance to save the galaxy place oh wow I  know and almost hit me  guardians of the galaxy vol 2 rated  pg-13  you